depuis le 1er janvier l'euro sous sa
forme fiduciaire à 20 ans alors quel
bilan pour les consommateurs français
les prix ont-ils réellement explosé
comme on le dit souvent en partie oui
entre 2002 et 2021 ils ont bondi de 31%
en gros ce qui coûtait 100 euros en 2002
coûte maintenant 131 euros en moyenne
cela fait une inflation de 1,3 pour cent
par an une inflation présente mais bien
moins importante qu entre 86 et de mina
où a été de 2,1 pour cent par an et
qu'entre l'après guerre des années 80 où
elles atteignaient plus de 10% par an
des chiffres fournis par l'insee à
relativiser puisqu'il se cale sur l'
indice des prix à la consommation qui
s'appuie sur un panier type et ne prend
pas en compte certaines données on vous
en avait déjà parlé dans ces caches mais
l'euro ce n'est pas que les prix à la
consommation en prenant en compte
l'ensemble de l'économie et sa
prospérité en 2019 un film tank
bruxellois a établi que chacun de nos
voisins allemands avaient gagné 23
mixant 16 euros supplémentaires en vingt
ans grâce à l'instauration de la monnaie
unique pendant que nous français nous en
aurions perdu 55 1996 en gros nous
aurions eu en poche en moyenne chaque
mois 2 146 euros supplémentaires si le
franc était resté la monnaie du pays
[Musique]